herzlich willkommen leute zu einer neuen
folge ich fahre ich bin heute in der
nähe von gütersloh und nicht für heute
den bmw i8 von alex und elektrisch
[Musik]
der yahoo guck mal hier flügeltüren
leute das erste auto in diesem format
mit flügeltüren das ist schon mal
richtig frech hier guck mal da
wir gucken erst mal hinten auf die
reifen drauf dann hast du hinten für
schlappen 2 45 das ist ein bisschen
breiter aber das ist noch okay auf jeden
fall gelochte bremsscheiben sehen wir ja
auch dass die frösche aus unfall lebens
amg hat hinten 315 erreichen also noch
mal echt richtig dann kann ich nicht mit
trotzdem ein geiles auto leute wir haben
hier einen plug in hybrid also der i8
ist wirklich ein verrücktes autolack in
hybrid das heißt hier hinten hier hinten
wohl gemerkt da ist der motor darunter
ist eine 3 zylinder 1,5 liter benziner
mit 231 ps 320 newtonmeter hat der
benziner nur drei zylinder leute das ist
weniger als 1,6 tdi golf also es
interessantes konzept aber trotzdem
extrem laut genau hin und er ist ein
clown der ist wirklich laut leute ich
bin hinter alex zum ärger von den ist
wirklich laut
dazu kommt noch ein elektromotor mit 143
ps das macht in summe 374 p 374 ps und
das ganze auto ist im ultra futuristisch
und verrückt das wird nicht mehr gebaut
leute zwar 2020 wurde die produktion
eingestellt und du kannst du kurz den
motor zeigen ja kein problem da macht
man einfach standard gemäß den kopf
warum auch ja das ist egal reise dieses
auto ist wirklich ein paar das hier
immer hohen habe ihn dahin sich wenn sie
jetzt leider nicht so viel zeigen weil
das ist halt so leute hier denken leute
denken okay grund ist dass eine kühlbox
das ist der motor das ist heiß war das
der mutter runter ich würde ich denke du
hast du die limits drin wir sehen hier
wir haben das coupé den ie8 gibt es auch
noch als roadster als cabrio auch geil
und diese flügeltüren junge wild und
schaut mal ganz nah dran das hier ist
eine weitere besonderheit von mir und
von mir 8 und ein ganz ganz vielen
anderen dieses material was ihr hier
seht ist cfk also der der wagen ist
nicht in stahl gebaut nicht in alu
sondern die fahrgastzelle die wir sehen
dass wir auch hier unten das ist cfk
also kohlefaserverstärkten kunststoffen
ist 50 prozent leichter als stahl
bauweise währenddessen aber nur 30
prozent leichter ist krankes auto muss
man wirklich sagen der motor dieses
antriebskonzept wurde von ich glaube
2015 bis 2019
gehend als bester motor des jahres
prämiert
das wusste ich nicht mal ja und das ist
komplett einfach kommen sich also leute
kommen das ist doch alles schon will
muss ich sagen das ist schon wild und er
wird einfach nicht mehr produziert
verrückt aber alex eine sache muss dir
sagen ja da muss man kurz
kennzeichenhalter ja ich weiß was ist
das denn hier da ist ja noch der cancan
nicht gleich einziehen und meiner
familie aber da muss ich als
verteidigung sagen ich hab den ja aus
münchen abgeholt von bmw
die hatten keine kurzen was das denn
alles kann man doch erwarten oder aber
im fall des kennzeichens ja das ist auch
das ist schon nach fast im urlaub heraus
ja ich weiß das muss ich mal optimieren
aber ich sehe gut aus trier hat nichts
gesehen dass hier ich weiß nicht warum
das diese hochwassers die batterie ist
oder keine ahnung aber hier ist eine
fette kannte und dadurch wusste ihr
wirklich als ich ich glaube mich so
immer zeigen wie man da richtig
einstellen muss man das mal zeigen aber
es ist immer alles dreckig was das denn
dann zeigt wie es richtig geht also das
wurde so weit ich weiß hat bmw mal so
ein video gemacht wie man wie man in den
g8 ein scheck
das ist muss man auch zu dem auge
letztlich einfach so rein fall ja da
darfst einfach aber auch nicht alt sein
und nicht zu viel auf den ofen werfen
helfen das stimmt wobei mein opa ist
auch schon mitgefahren und erst 90
ja krass aber das ist wirklich so bei
dem auto leute du brauchst für alle sind
erklärt video bei das auto ist nicht
normal wir können gerade eben das
problem zeigen was du hat dass alex
wollte gerade wischwasser nachfüllen ja
schaut mal nach kannst du die motorhaube
aufmachten guckt erst mal wo man die auf
macht ihr da machst das hier ab was ist
da denn wunder denn dann ziehst du das
hier raus sagt und dann ist die
motorhaube nicht auf weil das vielleicht
muss man auf der anderen seite auch noch
mal machen dann machen wir das hier noch
mal ein bisschen dieses bändchen hier um
und jetzt kannst du die hochziehen also
wie machst du machst sie so von oben auf
und musste dann auch festhalten so weit
ich weiß also wie kannst du kannst hier
unten fronten noch mal schieben oder so
du kannst das leicht hoch aber mehr geht
dann nicht sofort jetzt guck mal hier
wir grade eben so jacobi zwischen rhein
hier nein das glaube ich nicht dass
kühlflüssigkeit vorne sowieso noch mal
kühlflüssigkeit das für die klima jetzt
sag mal wo es wasser
dann kommt hier ich habe wirklich ohne
scheiß drei stunden gesucht im internet
du findest nichts dazu und dann habe ich
plötzlich diese klappe entdeckt das
kannst du dir dann aufwachen und hier
rein füllen
ja das ist wirklich super das habe ich
noch nie gesehen aber ja ich würde sagen
wahllos leute los und dann genau sprites
leer leute dass wir werden heute wenn
ihr jetzt auf den tagesschau wir werden
auch durch den dreh durchgekommen ohne
zu tanken aber damit damit ihre gärten
damit ihr nicht getötet werden von einem
leeren tank leer
es ist so wie 5% akku beim iphone das
sieht man ja dass ich gerne dann
deswegen danken wir für euch nochmal
leute also man merkt man beim fahren des
public sportlich sonder nicht ganz
optimal war
ja genau das ist hart und wir fangen
gerade rein elektrisch wieder auch jo
stimmt an welchem punkt kriegt
eigentlich der benziner rein also du
kannst bis 110 kannst du ein elektrisch
fahren so weit ich weiß also angegeben
ist es glaube ich offiziell mit 110 so
ab 110 oder halt wenn du keinen einer
kombination aus wohl aber was ist wenn
jetzt elektrisch fährt und dann machst
dann kommt der benziner kommt der und
der krieg dann direkt auf die fresse
aber jetzt noch also das dauert
irgendwie immer so ein bisschen ist das
so richtig beides zusammen harmoniert
und auf leistung kommen weiß so ok also
wenn ich denn jetzt anmache und einmal
gastgeber dann hat er noch nicht seine
volle power leute vielleicht weiß ist
einer von euch weil ich weiß dass gerade
nicht wird der benziner vom e motor
irgendwie vorgewärmt oder so weil kann
ja auch nicht sein dass du dann 30
minuten auf erst und dann geht es einmal
kicker und der benziner ist kalten krieg
decken interesse habt ihr ja zwei sachen
auch die erste frage ist natürlich was
bedeutet das für dich kannst du
vielleicht beantworten ich wollte vor
noch mal wissen das ding hier i8 ist ja
auch schwer teuer zumindest liste ja ist
ja du hast ganz gut um leasing gekommen
aber weißt was den listenpreis hat der
hier kostet 149 1009 den mit 17.000 km
bekommt den hut vor so ein mechaniker
von bmw für ein halbes jahr und von den
direkt spitze und dann möchte ich mir
das immer und jetzt drei jahre alt habe
ich den also dass ich mein auto aber
trotzdem bot ich würde kurz trinken
gehen josef das ist auch interessant
wartet das kann ich den mal zeigen du
musst hier auf diesen knopf drücken ja
und dann steht da tank bereitschaft wird
hergestellt und dann kann es sollte erst
die klappe öffnet also dass sie den
knopf in der tür genau analysiert am tag
oder der tank bereitschaft hergestellt
und dann erst ist tanken möglich genau
vorher stand nicht möglich vorher nicht
nein also man braucht geduld wenn man
gedacht hat dass hier ist übrigens der
tank denn alex mal unter dem was man
drücken und dann wird die tankbereich
erst mal hergestellt also hier liebe ja
acht fahrer draußen und ihr acht
interessenten
ihr dürft nicht zu eilig haben erst mal
ruhig der ie8 überlegt sich erstmal aufs
tanken möchte auch noch sehr interessant
hier
hier geht die tür auf ja nicht hier
unten nada massing hier geht die tür auf
viren tesla jetzt kann man ja mode
locken
und dann sieht man alexa wieder
zuklappen oh ja ich bock drauf meter vor
ihr film heute danke so leute ungesunden
zucker scheiß getankt es ist gar nicht
so ungesund ja sportler wird man
sportlich wenn man das trinken geht auch
ohne sport ja okay ist gar nicht so viel
zucker drin aber trotzdem da mache ich
mir mehr sorgen darum als um die impfung
ehrlich gesagt wenn ich mir allein nach
hause und blaues zeug
das ist irgendwie verändere wird christa
denn bei und wenn ihr das video sehen
heute bin ich am tag davor geimpft
worden und befolgt debatte anfängt ich
habe von einer fremden ärztin ein attest
bekommen fremd die mich behandelt es
keine gefährlichkeit attestiert eine
vorerkrankung trio zweimal aber erst mal
lustige was bedeuten autos für dich also
ich war ein wirklich nie auf autos
fokussiert so immer auch als ich 12 13
uhr es gibt ja leute die entwickeln
anschauen oder jaja totale leidenschaft
für autos ja ich hatte keine ahnung von
autos ich wusste ich konnte nicht mal
ein mercedes von bmw unterscheiden
gefühlt und das kam dann so ein bisschen
als ich dann mit youtube angefangen habe
und mir irgendwann gesagt habe ich
konnte jetzt oder ich konnte mir dann so
ein auto leisten dann habe ich mit
mustern das war mein erstes auto nicht
mehr dann geholt
als ich 19 war und da hat sich das dann
so zunimmt mehr entwickelt aber ich kann
jetzt auch sagen also autos sind geil
und ich freue mich auf jeden tag hier
mitzufahren
aber es gibt halt viel wichtigere dinge
im leben würde ich mal behaupten zum
beispiel motorräder motorräder überhaupt
nicht da hab ich da bin ich raus dass
wenn ich zu gefährlich ich habe mein
neues gesagt wo drei tage ja genau aber
es ist halt was ich immer schön finde
selbst wenn du weißt der tag will das
nicht zu besonders du kannst immer ein
bisschen die acht fallen das macht spaß
und das wäre das ganze so ein bisschen
auf aber für mich ist es jetzt wenn ich
jetzt hier meine drei jahre durch habe
dann reicht's mir sondern sportausschuss
denke ich ja also der wagen ist ja auch
straff die sicht nach hinten ist
allgemein über mögliche streben um dich
rum so du hast nicht so die kleinste
sich ja übrigens solvent und puzzle das
ist das ja micro ich einmal hier und
wenn nur das jahr über schiebt haben sie
einen sportmodus ja das mache ich auch
super gerne und dann kanns halt selber
damit scheiden da kommt der mutter war
sehr gut und der sound mit hinaus box da
ist ein 3 3 zylinder leute dreizylinder
das ist mehr als ich sechs ist schon
krass also wer macht wirklich alarm
dafür da ja noch nicht alarm ist dafür
das ist der benziner ist ja glaube ich
relativ verändert wie 8 also ich weiß
meine yacht kam zu zwölf oder so das ja
ja zu elft glaube ich sogar so das ist
ja neun oder zehn ja gar nicht
beschreiben das ja eigentlich ein alter
da weißt du was das lustigs ist ich habe
einen monat gefahren dann habe ich das
erste für den sport modus ja also das
man auch selber entscheiden kann
allerdings auch im fall der kg soffie
der profitrate mal ganz ganz cool
ganz kurz er du könntest mal dass man
eben noch einen soundcheck machen ich
bin mal gespannt wie der von halblinks
sind
es ist schon ordentlich das ist schon
ordentlich da von außen auch angehört
hat gute an der das von außen komplett
da ich habe das noch nie so selber von
außen muss ich sagen
man hat es nicht größer aus
deswegen wäre nicht mehr
der linke aus profession für sound
ehrlich jetzt
ja hallo der sound
vorne von rechts kommt nix
deshalb hat er vielleicht nur eigene
ausbruch hatte vielleicht nur ein nur
links
das super league okay wir drücken einmal
staat ja okay wir fangen elektrisch los
du musst darum raus hier aber
klassisches bmw problem der blick
springt nicht zurück in position
ja doch wenn du richtig um die kurve
fährt ja ja aber nicht an seine finger
und hier kommen jetzt eigentlich nur die
ganze zeit geradeaus fahren hier kommt
jetzt das erste stück limitiert und
limitiert wie heißt das unbeschränkte
unlimitiert und hier kann es jetzt
eigentlich einmal drücken weil so kannst
du auch gleich noch mal so ein
tempolimit ist dann sagt man limitierte
edition erwartet perfekt hier
der motor hat man ja ist an ich hoffe
wirklich nur für den motor das ja auch
vorgewärmt wird weil sonst nichts
und 3
und nichts
[Musik]
geil das ist ja gratuliert alter diese
kombi ist er komplett wir leider musste
ich richtig lust was würdest du sagen
von der beschädigung von der
beschleunigung du bist jetzt schon
ziemlich viele autos geht er ich bin ja
auch absolute killer autisten tempo 70
heute gibt er auch schon absolute killer
autos gefahren also das ist ja ich bin
letzte woche nach hamburg gefahren aber
es ist dann schon auch mal was ganz
anderes
also die beschleunigung die kriegt hier
auch gut aber es ist nicht so dass links
und mein gott ich muss dich festhalten
will auch beim bike ist also jetzt schon
eine sehr gute beschreibung muss man
sein okay aber krass ist dieses
fahrwerks wirklich so eingestellt
gefühlt kann ich hier über über so ein
zigarettenstummel drüber fahren kann er
die marke sagen das kann ich erfüllen
das ist wirklich also gespült sehr
verbunden mit der straße gespannt auf
die kurven gleich ich glaube die kurven
sind nicht so der berner da drin also in
dem auto oder mit dem auto aber trotzdem
vom allgemeinen fahrgefühl ist es
einfach so todes sicher also ich finde
ich habe klar ich bin vorher muss dann
gefahren das ist es aber was ganz
anderes werk antrieb aber es ist einfach
du fühlst dich sicher weil es ja auch
die bremsen und so das ist alles so das
passt einfach die hat doch auch ein
antrieb ihre nein nein wenn der e motor
mit
misch der macht er jetzt auch mal lagen
daher hast du beide reifen macht der e
motor hat die vorderachse und der
benziner dahinter genau richtig
[Musik]
der sound ist schon geil wo sie sagen
also was die da aus einem dreizylinder
rausholen das ist wirklich aller ehren
wert kurvenlage das lenkrad als auch
einen widerstand der ui nicht gut doch
also fühlt sich sehr connected ein fühlt
sich sehr sehr direkt
aber der ball nicht mehr
[Musik]
geil dass auch ein head up display genau
head-up-display habe ich auch da ist das
geil ist sogar wenn du na wie ananas
meist wird der ihr die straße da ins
head up display projiziert
da bin ich sehr cool sind es leute da es
ist hertz display flackert ein bisschen
bei euch bei mir ist es konstant und
gemacht
bis film auch alex
[Musik]
niebels geil wie man so hört wie der
hybrid und der verbrenner zusammenarbeit
börse aber trotzdem mutter wieder
eingestellt ja ich hab gelesen weil
problem der ist einfach zu teuer für die
leistung oder leute die so viel geld für
ein auto ausgeben kaufen sich dann eher
forsche ja also also sagen mal 370 ps
[Musik]
150000 euro ist einfach zu viel
150000 dreizylinder nein du hast ja auch
spottbillig bekommen im leasing weil
eben die autos nicht weggehen bis er ein
bisschen kurvenlage testen
ja der liegt schon flach er liegt schon
flach und gut in der chor ist unser
ja geil jetzt hier mal ein paar rubel
die macht er gut weg also der bleibt die
ganze zeit in einer straße dran so
gefühlt was keine aussetzer aber wie
gesagt also für 450.000 euro kriegst du
was kriegst du da alles da kriegst b63 s
612 ps v8 der dir wirklich die fußnägel
hoch zieht der gast was waren bei der
jetzt also dass bei welchem auto am
meisten spaß von denen die in den duden
die uhr gefahren ist
[Musik]
bei dem lambo wahrscheinlich oder das
ist schwer zu sagen sich viele geile
haus 2 gewesen
ich hatte richtig krass spaß beim dts
von mark iv muss ich sagen okay
der war richtig krass weil er einfach so
geil aus dieser james bond mäßig und
auch noch komfort kann aber auch so
alarm macht ist der gts halten sagen
lambo natürlich auch kraft sky also
wirklich sehr wohl auf der straße ohne
zu berechtigt zu sein
[Musik]
kommen wir damit zum werterhalt und zur
ersten kategorie dem aussehen der a8 ist
wirklich schon ein fesches auto muss man
ganz klar sagen aber ich finde der ist
nicht ganz auf dem level mit zum
beispiel dem 911 gts von maribor der
acht von zehn punkte bekommen hat
deswegen bekommt der ie8 sieben von zehn
aber gute 720 die beschleunigung kann
sich auch gut sehen lassen 4,4 sekunden
von null auf hundert macht das coupé
elektromotor und verbrecher arbeiten gut
zusammen um zumindest in diesem bereich
von 0 besonders das auto richtig massiv
nach vorne zu schieben das ist zügig und
das gibt sieben von zehn punkten ist das
für mich persönlich die stärkste
kategorie von mir acht der ist einfach
irgendwie fresh muss man sagen immer
noch auch wenn er nicht mehr gebaut wird
die flügeltüren
das futuristische äußere einfach das
alles irgendwie anders ist dann im auto
macht das ganze schon sehr cool ist
meiner meinung nach die stärkste
kategorie form ii 8 8 von 10 punkten
praktikabilität ja leute gar nicht -
punkte geben also jetzt ja selbst
gesehen das auto ist nicht wirklich
praktisch du hast quasi gar keinen
kofferraum der pass vielleicht ein
sixpack bier hinten rein
vor den motor mehr worte nicht wenn es
nicht besser weiß wirst du stundenlang
den wischwasser einfüllstutzen suchen
und die motorhaube geöffnet würde es
auch einfach komplett crazy zwei von
zehn ist durchaus angebracht und auch
bei der preis leistung heute nacht nicht
gut weg das ist meiner meinung nach der
größte kritikpunkt sogar an dem wagen
ist ja immer auch ein sportwagen und so
und deswegen kann er in seiner
sportwagen auch bestehen wenn er nicht
praktisch ist aber er ist einfach meiner
meinung nach viel zu teuer für das was
er leistet 150000 euro für diese
konfiguration für den dreizylinder
benziner plus elektromotor ist einfach
nicht wettbewerbsfähig in meinen augen
zwei von zehn was schließlich den kopf
vorgeht muss man schon ganz klar sagen
dass sie achten ein bisschen härter
gefehlt hat ist also da muss man sich
darauf einstellen er ist aber nicht so
bret hart wie zum beispiel der hurrikan
aber ist schon
nicht auf der sicheren seite des lebens
trotzdem kann man ihn wenn man den ball
drin sitzt und über diese schwelle
drüber gekommen ist ganz gut fahren bis
er das fahrwerk aber ansonsten ist es
ein entspanntes auto was einen nicht die
ganze zeit nervt er möchte der hofer
kann von der kriegs hat drei von zehn
bekommen die beiden neuen elfer von marc
gebauer und luca 15 deswegen ist der ie8
würde ich sagen hier mit vier von zehn
ganz gut mit und jetzt bleibt nur zu
sagen leute ich freue mich riesig auf
den nächsten samstag denn es wird wieder
einen amg geben ich bin richtig halb bis
dahin macht's gut abonniert main kanal
wenn euch die videos gefallen und ciao